logitech rolled out a new headset the g4
33 and it sets itself apart from
companies other headsets by sticking to
the basics it's not flashy
it offers decent sound and it's the most
comfortable headset from Logitech thus
far but it is gonna cost you a hundred
dollars alright let's break down the g4
33 an immediate stand out from handling
this headset is that it feels solid it's
not flimsy or fragile which is
surprising giving it's plastic frame it
also doesn't make annoying creaking
sounds like other headsets built with
plastic since its intended to be the
sort of everyday life style of headset
the gaudy gamer aesthetic is gone the g4
33 comes with plenty in the package
you'll get two 3.5 millimeter cables one
that's braided and approximately six and
a half feet long and another that's a
little shorter just under 5 feet more
suitable for mobile use the flexible
microphone detaches with ease and makes
sense for mobile scenarios it comes with
an audio and mic splitter in case you're
using a device that doesn't have the
combo 3.5 millimeter port a USB digital
to analog converter or DAC allows the g4
33 to use DTS headphone X which is
virtual 7.1 surround sound but it's
exclusive to pcs you also get a little
mesh travel pouch to take them on the go
in addition to the stock mesh ear pads
you have the choice of microfiber at
your pads to swap in please pop out
easily but it takes a little bit of work
to get back in I much prefer to the
microfiber since the mesh feels little
rough and doesn't grip my head as well
now I haven't exactly been a fan of
logitech's headsets in the past since I
found them to be uncomfortable for long
sessions however the g4 33 is a
significant improvement although it's
not the best in terms of comfort I can
use these through an entire workday or
gaming session without irritation it
tends to clamp a bit tightly but not to
the point where it's unbearable for my
own personal setup I switch between
Sennheiser HD 5 5/8 and audio Technica's
8 th M 50 X's depending on the situation
now you won't get the same exact level
of sonic fidelity with a g4 33 but the
sound impressive within the gaming
headset space I listen to a wide range
of music genres and use lossless files
to get the cleanest audio possible
strong bass shines through even tapping
into a little bit of the sub bass for
real deep rattling notes without
drowning out other frequencies mids and
highs come out clean but they tend to
sound distorted up louder volumes come
on when it comes to gaming the G 433
sounds just as good if not better than
headsets in this price range battlefield
one felt full and immersive with
explosions going off gunfire to my left
and right planes flying overhead and
soldiers screaming commands across the
trenches even out louder volumes all of
these different sounds didn't seem harsh
or overbearing Forza horizon 3 sounded
great as well although he didn't need
detailed sound for tactical purposes it
was nice to hear the engines roar over
its diverse soundtrack
this is what you should expect from a
gaming headset that costs $100 through
the USB DAC and logitech gaming software
you can customize your EQ settings and
activate DTS headphone X which is a
solution for virtual 7.1 surround sound
although it gave battlefields a little
bit more depth than a better soundstage
Audio felt a little hollow as if the
events occurred in the concert hall
rather than that of the battlefield
microphone quality is a definite
highlight the micro pop filter helps
suppress the harshness of s and P sounds
and chatting in discord was clean the
boom mic does a decent job of not
picking up outside noises while it
wouldn't exactly be in audio files first
choice the G 433 succeeds as a
jack-of-all-trades so if you're willing
to spend a hundred dollars on a gaming
headset this should be on your radar if
you're looking to complete your gaming
setup check out our comparison of razors
and hyper X's mice and subscribe to
GameSpot for more thanks for watching